You're getting married.
It's such a huge deal.
I can't believe
it's happening to me.
Neither can we.
Psych, you're the best.
You guys are
my best friends.
Okay, open your
presents, bitch.
( Amy )
Yes, yes, yes.
Phil!
I use the same
kind myself.
Let's just say it
really knows what it's doing.
Okay.
Me next,
me next, me next.
This is called the Herminator
and it's the same one I use.
It has an alarm clock
and voice control.
It is the best.
No offense.
None taken.
Actually, speaking
of the best, open mine.
Oh, boom!
Yeah, it's the Good Vibrations
Sweet Sensations,
and this thing
makes my eyes pop out
of my head and become
my vagina.
Um, I just found
the battery life on those
things to be dog shit.
Um, actually, it's also
a Boingo hotspot
and I know you travel a lot,
so I'm just really considerate.
We haven't opened
my gift yet.
It has GPS, you can
download 5,000 songs on it.
Did I mention that you can link
mine up to your Facebook page?
You know what, mine also
functions as a mezuzah,
for when you
and Adam get a place.
Holy cow!
Oh, a mezuzah's just
what Jewish people hang
outside their door
to feel safe.
I know.
You guys are
amazing friends.
Yeah, but like,
I'm your best friend
and I just want you
to know that I care
about your vagina more
than I care about my own
and that's like the most
possible you can care,
if that makes sense.
It does make sense.
But I also care about
your vagina a ton.
You know, sometimes
too much, I wonder.
I do wonder that.
You know, I just--
for me, I just really
want your vagina to
be on the brink
of exhaustion
at all times.
Carly, I haven't
opened yours yet.
All the other gifts were so
amazing, it's embarrassing.
Let's keep it light,
Carly.
Come on!
Okay.
Now you know I don't
make a lot of money
working at the
Container Store.
We do know, Carly.
We know, because you've
said it a number of times.
There's nothing we can do about
how much you get paid there.
So I kind of made
you something.
What is it?
It's also a vibrator.
That's us sophomore year
at the Grand Canyon.
Oh Carly,
this is the best one.
Really?
This is my favorite one.
You guys,
isn't this the best one?
It is nice,
colorful.
Here, pass it around.
It took about nine
hours from sketching
it out to its full
realization.
Oh no.
Oh.
Oh, I guess
the glue's not dry.
I'm sure you just
stick it back on.
Some of the shells
are still sandy.
Just be careful,
I guess.